hey guys I'm Ryan Wright and I'm Arianna
we're gonna check out a video today that
I'm pretty excited to see it's from top
5 called 5 youtubers turned killers the
true story of Arianna and right top 5
unknowns it's crazy to think that these
youtubers had turned into killers and
that we can watch to their descend into
madness through their videos welcome to
5 youtubers turned killers number 5 trey
eric Sessler under the username of lenss
cut productions he also went by the name
of mr. anime he had a small following on
YouTube he uploaded anime reviews gaming
videos special effect videos and blogs
on the 20th of March 2012 he killed his
mother father and brother he confessed
to the police that he killed them
because he was planning to go on a
Columbine like massacre and didn't want
his family to know about it the 22 year
old at the time was found after a
day-long manhunt following the discovery
of the bodies of his relatives which
were covered in gunshot wounds luckily
police were able to find him before the
massacre took place he told the police
that he and a friend were planning a
mass shooting at a local high school in
Waller Texas according to former
students from his high school they said
Trey was obsessed with the 1999
Columbine massacre he was also obsessed
with guns and had several handguns and
high-powered rifles at his home he was
charged with capital murder when police
searched a home they said it was
ransacked and there was rioting all over
the walls some included I love my mum
dad and brother and God forgive me
because I cannot forgive myself his
third from last video was titled mr.
anime is planning something he didn't
say what he was planning but he said he
would need to take a three week break
for it saying that he was going to
reward himself three weeks after the
video was uploaded was when he murdered
his family I'm going to reward myself
with a probably a two or three week
break coming up here from YouTube videos
Wow Anthony Powell using the username
The Prodigy 2048 he would make hateful
videos towards black women an atheist he
had a video titled black women don't
deserve respect some of his videos had a
fair amount of views but were met with
many dislikes and angry comments in
April of 2009
Anthony murdered another youtuber by the
name of aja I'm a-goin Amir I had a
small following on YouTube she would
upload videos of her dancing and singing
28 year old Anthony murdered 20 year old
aja and a college classroom in Detroit
he then killed himself it was revealed
that Anthony may have been stalking aja
as one of Asia's friends and patted her
on Facebook and would message her
repeatedly it's also believed that he
had another YouTube account called
Detroit man 303 I share and would
frequently post comments on Asians
videos on my ages last video was a video
of her address in YouTube haters
Anthony's last video was a rant about
black women as of 2015 Anthony's account
has been deleted by someone although
some of his videos have been reloaded
Anthony's parents said that her son had
a history of mental illness the police
knew about Anthony and his behavior as
somebody from Detroit had reported his
YouTube account to the FBI and claimed
that he was a dangerous man
number 3 pecker Eric Othman otherwise
known as the YouTube killer he went by
the username ster Geist 89 he had over a
hundred and thirty videos uploaded he
would mainly upload videos bashing all
different religions such as Christianity
Islam and Judaism he would also upload
hateful videos about God and videos of
him shooting guns in the woods in some
videos he described himself as a social
Darwinist who would eliminate all who he
sees as unfit on the 7th of November
2007 18 year-old Pekka went to Jola High
School in a town of to sila Finland
armed of a semi-automatic pistol he
killed eight people then shot himself in
the head weeks before the shooting he
had uploaded a video titled joke Allah
high school massacre 11:50 7th 2007 it
showed a picture of the school then
transitioned to a picture of him holding
a gun it was a warning for the attack he
had also stated that
this is my war one man's war against
humanity government a weak-minded masses
of the world after an investigation the
police had found out that Pekka was
being bullied at the school and some
teachers had also noticed his strange
behavior one had even set up for him to
see a psychiatrist but he never showed
up as of 2015 the original warning video
has been removed but it was reloading
also if you try to search for his
username in a browser search bar it
redirects to a different account number
two Jared Lee Lautner using the username
class at up ten he uploaded bizarre
videos about religion and mind control
he also had videos about a new currency
that he created he has a small following
but his videos have large number of
views these only came after the horrific
acts he had committed on January 8th
2011 he shot and killed six people
including a judge and a nine-year-old
girl he also showed a gun shot another
13 people it all took place in a
supermarket parking lot in tuckson
Arizona his target was gabrielle
Giffords
an American politician who represented
Arizona 8th congressional district jared
managed to shoot her but then kill her
however she did suffered severe brain
injury after a police investigation it
was found out that Jared was a
conspiracy theorist and was obsessed
with them especially the movies
zeitgeist it was only found out that he
was somewhat of an alcoholic and would
frequently smoke salvia months before
the shooting his parents became
increasingly alarmed as we leave here
they disabled his car every night and
also confiscated his guns in 2012 he
pled guilty to six counts of murder and
13 counts of attempted murder his videos
are still available to watch on his
channel
now I'm belong on a yacht Roger under
the username elliot rodger he uploaded
regular style short vlogs he had a
decent amount of subscribers his final
videos took a strange turn
some were titled why do girls hate me so
much and life is so unfair because girls
don't want me in them it would describe
how lonely and miserable he was and
complained that no beautiful girls ever
gave him a chance on May 23rd 2014
Elliot killed six people
and injured 14 others in Isla Vista
California he then committed suicide the
attack began when 22 year old Elliot
stabbed three men to death in his
apartment he then drove to a sorority
house and shot three students killing
two he then drove to it daily and shot
to death a male student he then got in
his car and began to speed through Isla
Vista and started randomly shooting
pedestrians he then began to get chased
by the police a gun battle ensued and
the madness finally came to an end after
Elliot's crashed his car and the police
found him dead with a self-inflicted
gunshot wound to the head on the day of
the rampage Elliot uploaded a video to
YouTube titled Elliot Rogers retribution
in it he disgusted details of his
upcoming attack and his motivations he
said he was doing it as a punishment
towards women for rejecting him he also
said that he has a desire to punish
sexually active men for living a better
life than his the video had been deleted
from his YouTube page shortly after but
many of his videos still remain on his
channel including five that you uploaded
on the day of the attack his videos now
have millions of views in response to
the horrific event that took place thank
you so much for watching if you enjoyed
the video don't be sure to give it a big
thumbs up and don't forget to subscribe
to keep updated with our videos yeah I
don't want into the deal oh wow how do
you even react to that there's like this
misconception that I notice a lot of
commenters commentators have they'll
look at someone's subscriber count and
assume that everything is like good in
their life because oh well their youtube
channels going good and stuff so to see
this that's I did not know about any of
these I knew about Isla Vista oh you did
yeah people a lot of you from my high
school went to school where he like did
the shooting that's crazy how a lot of
these people were like they felt
connected to those who followed them
that's like they were using it as of a
way to communicate and talking about
like hey they were giving you hints that
they're gonna commit acts right but it's
weird cuz it's like they're
communicating with such a large amount
of people about it none of these are
stopped
yeah and they feel like they're kind of
understood maybe
and then they act on it it's not like
that's just incredibly disturbing like
the first guy they said killed his
parents parents and brother so they
wouldn't find out that he wanted to kill
more people oh my god I feel like all I
can do is like be a PSA be like get help
I mean I wanna crack jokes but I feel
like it's very appropriate time yeah
right yeah it's like trust rooks going
on in the noggin right now no but I know
that all that would upset people the one
guy who was like he hates black woman
first off I want to establish I like
black woman there's some of my favorite
things to watch on pornhub calm it's
[ __ ] up that someone would go out of
his way to make videos specifically
attacking black woman it kind of feels
like cultish in a way like look at my
following and I'm gonna commit this
horrible crime also they're becoming
miniature they think they're kind of
celebrity ties yeah Oh Columbine and
that was something that he looked up to
they think they're like leaders who have
something to say and that they have a
message to put out there and stuff
because I got a following like so sad
and so tragic and that girl he killed
she was beautiful and she was like a
great dancer it's it's like that sucks
so much I mean it doesn't sound like
even really knew her I'm surprised the
[ __ ] witch guy was I gave a date and
the location hecka Erik of mcfillin like
this guy someone should have said
something like his videos practically
led to right yeah it was like a build up
of videos that were leading to the
massacre it's scary because YouTube is
such a world for entertainment and then
you find out there are people out there
who are treating it like you know and
community but these people are finding
their own community yeah negative way
it's like Charles Manson online except
they're not getting a bunch of people to
kill for them you know I feel like if I
were to be some type of you know killer
I would want fans to do it for me
not me myself don't give ideas well I'm
just saying that like I'm not gonna say
who I want to like but I might calling
you guys check no time for jokes in this
video people no time for jokes here's a
comedy channel but we go
uh ray you gotta cut back here when it
comes to killings is like you know what
if they kill it they're all bad all
killings are bad but killing kids are
going to a high school massacre like
that's a fact that that is just not cool
man like you don't kill anyone but
especially a kid like you don't even
harm a kid no I wish we watch this video
first and then transition into some
comedy videos because this is now
earnest this is really dark and I are
gonna leave and you gotta leave with
this darkness this Jewish darkness you
had going
but the Elliott Rodriguez guy have like
18,000 followers his stepmom was a real
housewife they're like a California
family someone's in the entertainment
business
he had like nice cars had everything and
just was really upset that like he
wasn't having sex with girls yeah I mean
it's you can paste girls have sex with
you hope you can it's a business and
it's legal one should know Lisa Rinna
t'v Thank You Ariana I die if I need to
be proactive about this yeah you know
you're not getting laid you can pay
someone if you feel like hurting people
because you're not getting laid you can
have sex with therapists or that be on
medication for things there's ways to
seek help and right like these guys
aren't completely alone they they should
have they must know at least someone
who's like hey maybe you should get some
help you know like there are things that
might have clues or have led up to them
I doubt people are like I was totally
surprised they did this you know and
that guy just like he was on a [ __ ]
massacre driving around shooting
pedestrians and [ __ ] and I thought the
argument is it's YouTube everyone's
entitled to say whatever they want I
feel like that's why people don't just
shut this down yeah but these are
warning signs yes definitely and no
one's entitled to shooting other people
no no unless you're in a war we go from
this to yeah it's kind of surprising to
me because the Elliot guy I'm like he's
not a bad-looking guy and you know like
he clearly has a person out he had a
person I had people liked mental health
it's mental health I was really [ __ ]
up and
you know we all feel shitty sometimes I
do always yeah I know
it's like a consistent feeling when
you're and then when you're happy you go
why am i happy I felt that last week
mm-hmm I woke up I was like I feel not
anxious and then you look for things to
be anxious about yeah and then I got
yeah and the other thing that I'm
noticing about this a lot of this is
like sociology coming into play of like
what others opinions are and how it's
affected their feedback from being
online yeah exactly
thumbs down or the thing we don't take
it as seriously yeah yeah yeah I mean
like that's why it's so important to not
give support to certain things maybe
it's not a good idea to do a reaction
and discussion to this video because
we're is making it more public I think
in a way it's a good warning sign to be
like if you notice someone is just a
personality on YouTube and something is
not right maybe you know don't leave me
comments but leave supportive comments
Brian what you need to talk refer them
to help because I'm sure what
contributes to them kind of giving in to
these dark this dark side is the dark
comments they were also getting in
return you know like because that could
feet fuel you and it's like it just
feeds on the darkness that you already
have anyway guys hopefully entertain you
see if you're new to the channel you can
subscribe to the real rejects it's
usually a lot of fun yeah but it's more
dark today because Halloween's coming up
that's why we did this video and you can
follow us on Facebook Instagram Twitter
vine and periscope and you can check out
Ariana's channel Arianna jus boss sorry
it's great stuff that's not what's
called right it's not Arianna jus boss
free clothes when you're running out of
dart jokes you just make a Jew joke